I think objectivity was a lie
objectivity was an effort to say I have
no opinions I'm kind of not human and I
can turn off all opinions I have and I
don't need to tell you anything about
myself because i decree myself objective
well no I think the public has a right
to know your background your perspective
your influences and in big and little
ways maybe you should put in a box of
all the links that you saw before you
wrote a story so that they know what
sources what influenced you I think the
transparency is a matter of respect and
Trust to the audience now then comes
intellectual honesty then if you say
well yeah okay i'm a democrat I've told
you i'm a democrat but i'm going to tell
you something that's kind of hurt the
democratic party because it's the right
thing to do you'll respect me for doing
that I think you'll respect me more for
me having told you that I'm a Democrat
so transparency is about the trust and
the relationship with the public you're
serving that i think is an ethic that we
can learn a lot from objectivity is
about hiding stuff objectivity is about
saying no no i'm not going to tell you
my opinions because that's somehow going
to make me more objective that's a lie
of omission